now what in the world is this it's twice
as long as a human body translucent and
kind of glowing thousands of hungry
mouths pulsate ready to gobble up
whatever they can these just might be
some of the most interesting least known
creatures in the ocean see cells they're
kind of like jellyfish or really more of
a huge chain of jelly like critters that
have formed an alliance
unlike jellyfish these gelatinous
oddities are coordinates making them
related to humans l distantly helps are
both beautiful and amazing
they often resemble a living diamond
necklace floating in the water
[Music]
each Sal can be up to four inches long
but the chains can be up to 15 feet long
they pump water through their bodies to
breathe catch food and move about as you
can see there is diverse as snowflakes
as beautiful as crystal chandeliers
drifting gracefully through the oceans
of the world
you
[Music]